[Music]
welcome back to GameSpot's III 2018
coverage i'm callie i am here with
senior vice president bethesda Pete
Hines thank you so much for joining me
oh how are you Callie I'm doing well
how's your show going crazy but good
it's busy pretty packed
especially judging by the press
conference seems like it started a
little bit earlier than you guys
necessarily wanted judging by that
Walmart Canada yeah yeah but you know
what we were still planning on teasing
it and putting out so we just sort of
rolled with it yeah so that was plans
yeah before the showcase we were
actually the Monday when we actually put
up the trailer was when we planned to
but they just leave did a few days early
so my team is awesome in there like I
were just gonna have some fun with it
and roll with it I was gonna say you
guys had a really good sense of humor on
Twitter about that I mean video games
were supposed to be fun and so whenever
you have a chance to have a little fun
you should so we decided to and it
worked out yeah one thing I noticed
about this year's press conference was
you know compared to last year you guys
showed off a lot of stuff that was
coming out in the months following so it
was a big 2017 showcase this one had a
little bit more for the far future even
can you talk a little bit about maybe
what the thinking was behind that sure
well if you look at what we had last
year like we just had a ton of games we
just felt like with everything that we
were releasing that year that we
honestly could afford to keep it the
focus on last year with wolf and evil
within and you know Nintendo switch
games and VR stuff so it was more just
like how much do we have and for this
year again it was like where do we feel
like everybody is and and what do we
want to show and what do we want to
announce and and you know in the case
that Bethesda Game Studios we wanted to
give I think a better sense of of what
their longer-term plan looks like not
just fall at 76 but future stuff just
because there's rumors and things
floating out we were just like let's
just tell everybody like this is what it
looks like make life a little easier and
as a result you get a pretty big mix of
things for this year things for next
year and things for beyond that mm-hmm
so I guess jumping into one of the
biggest things was Elder Scrolls 6 which
is the one that I was hoping and praying
for is there anything else you can can
tell us um is it is it in development is
what's going on like
what's going on with that I don't even
know what stage you would categorize it
in right now we are obviously full bore
on fallout 76 and as Todd has said we're
we're a fair ways along with starfield I
mean it's playable now so like fallout
76 gets the bulk of the attention and
starfield has some amount of attention
so test six being much further down the
road and you know some number of years
after right now you know
pre-production it's it's early mm-hmm
for starfield then if that one's a
little bit further along when can we
expect to see more of that probably a
lot closer to release again like it's
definitely further along but even across
Bethesda Game Studios which is now three
offices in Rockville Montreal and Austin
the bulk of those folks are working on
76 it's a massive project it's a massive
world and so you know starfield is gonna
still need some amount of time and
attention after this year to get
everything else that it needs because
it's an incredibly ambitious project
mm-hmm for fallout 76 I mean I'm sure I
mean we've got gotten to talk to Todd
Howard already about this and so I'm
just wondering what your take is on the
you know online multiplayer emphasis
especially for something that is
traditionally a pretty single-player
driven really story heavy RPG in terms
of like how that's gonna affect how you
play or how that how how that affects
you know somebody's perception of
fallout or how that does that evolve
fall under where is this kind of a
separate thing the main fallout both
like you know it's it is a sequel and
that is the next one in in fallout but
we didn't call it fallout 5 because it's
not it's not the same we are doing
something different and we are doing
something that that was a direction the
studio wanted to try and see how it work
and see what it would feel like I think
as folks get a better understanding of
what it is it's still at its core a
Fallout game you're still doing all of
the things you would do in a Fallout
game if it was if it was an offline
single-player
developing your character going on
quests exploring the world like the
emerging gameplay what's in that
building what's over there I'm gonna
kill those things and I want to craft
stuff I want to trade for things all of
that is still true you just had this
added element of when you see a person
in the world they're a real person and
now you have to figure out not how did
we script that character to interact
with you but that's being controlled by
a real person who might be role-playing
or doing any number of things maybe
they're being super helpful maybe
they're wandering the world as a traitor
and just trading with people maybe
they're being a bad guy and like they're
considered they're part of a Raider
group so allowing for that sort of
tension but with with systems in place
that keep it from being abusive so you
can't be you can't be harassed by
somebody who just keeps chasing you
around the world and keeps killing you
over and over again like the game
literally doesn't allow you that that to
happen to you and you don't death isn't
supposed to be a super negative thing
like you don't lose your progression you
don't lose all your stuff somebody can't
kill you and then take everything in
your inventory and you should start over
it doesn't it doesn't work like that at
all and I think once we figure out some
things we're sort of like tweaking like
maybe it should work like this or this
when you see it in action when you play
it when you feel it it just like it
feels like you're playing a Fallout game
I play it whenever I play it I play it
always by myself like I don't group up
with folks I just like going around and
seeing how does all of this play out and
and how does it feel when you're playing
it and so far like I really enjoy it I
love it so it's like the same sort of
role-playing that you experience and
follow just in a different sort of style
yeah think of it like all of those
interactions with NPCs that you come
across have traditionally been entirely
dictated by us we decided whether that
was a bad guy or a good guy or had
dialogue and now you don't have any idea
and so in that way it does feel more
like I just came out of this vault into
this world and I don't know how anybody
I come across is gonna interact with me
unless maybe I've interacted with them
before and we've traded stuff or
you know they were looking for X I was
looking for Y and we and we bartered but
maybe now they've they've turned bad and
right it's still always gonna be a
question in your mind of how am I gonna
am I gonna set up a shop with the big
neon sign that says guns for sale or all
of that is entirely up to you and it's
also not it's not set in a place where
you know I'm playing the game by myself
and you're playing the game by yourself
and we decide hey let's let's join up
and play together it's not like well can
you join my server it doesn't it doesn't
matter you can just see go to play and
go oh I see Pete's playing I'm gonna
jump on with DC Deacon into wherever he
is and now you're just in the same place
that I am and the stuff that you did
comes with you or you have multiple
characters you know like this is the one
that I use when I'm playing with this
group of friends and this is the one I
play when I'm just solo and this is my
good guy character all of those things
are still possible one thing I do want
to go back to really quickly before we
move on is the anti harassment stuff it
sounds like there's a lot of tweaking
involved a lot of you know trial and
error with that do you have plans to
continue monitoring those systems sure
yeah absolutely I mean it's a we look at
lots of things we've fallout 4 in Skyrim
our games as a service for us right they
have ongoing support that we provide for
them this is gonna be that to the
umpteenth degree where we're constantly
checking and monitoring you know Todd
talked about the beta we need to see how
folks react on that and how it feels but
again think of PvP more like issuing a
challenge to somebody as opposed to just
no matter what I want to do to somebody
I can it's more like issuing a challenge
and the game only lets that go so far
before you can basically say I don't I
don't want to participate in this
challenge anymore
oh that's really cool so you can
essentially like tap out kinda yeah like
think of it this way if you were just
playing fallout 4 and you were exploring
and came across a deathclaw
and you'd be like hmmm I don't know if I
have the weapons to deal with this or if
I'm high enough level but I'm gonna try
and you try and fight it and die and you
respawn you might say eh I'm gonna try
it again cuz I came close and I want to
kill it or you might say I didn't even
come close and I'm done and I'm gonna go
do something else
well that should kind of be how it works
for any human person where you're like
oh I want to get my revenge and try
again cuz I think I can take them and
you're incentivized to do that but you
could also say I'm good I'm all set I'm
gonna go do something else and they
can't keep coming after you just like
that deathclaw wouldn't come running
across the map and keep chasing it like
it should feel like it should feel like
that right so I guess on the fallout
note but a little different you guys
just released fallout shelter on PS
horns which I think understandably
because fallout is a big deal for you
guys this year with 76 but I'm wondering
about Elder Scrolls blades and if the
success of fallout shelter which todd
said a 120 million players which is more
than all of your games combined which is
incredible to me did that influence
elder scrolls blades at all absolutely
it did it not only informed it but it it
told us a lot about what we needed to do
to make blades a better game and how to
do that properly and quite honestly a
lot of the folks who made shelter happen
have been the folks leading the charge
on blades you know they've got a lot of
experience in mobile that's what allowed
us to make shelter a success and you
know it was rolling off of that where
Todd was like okay like I want us to go
big like we've been kicking this idea
around and like we're gonna go for it
like I want to do and you know he laid
out sort of what that looks like and
feels like starting with mobile but
eventually coming to basically any
platform that we can put it on including
all types of VR but to have that same
kind of experience of I I don't have
anything quite like this on my on my
phone or older supposed fans I mean I
know for me I'm the kind of person when
I get really into a game I like to read
the wiki on my phone just that's like if
I'm like I can't be playing right now I
might as well be reading about it or
something like that and so that's the
kind of game that I would want to have
with me I'm sure and it does offer a
variety of experiences amande he talked
about yesterday you know the town mode
is that is basically the base game that
is the story of you're one of the blades
you get sent back to your town it's in
Rouen and you have to build it back up
and in doing so you're doing quests
you're going out adventure you're
leveling up your character you're
getting new stuff you know
this is you know my favorite part cuz
this feels the most Elder Scrolls to me
right like going through and picking
what I want to what I want to wear and
what my character looks like and like
you know am I going for a whole elven
thing or who do I want to be in this
world on your phone whenever you want
but then you also have this element of
where you can go into the arena and play
competitively or you've got this abyss
mode like there's not just one way to
play but there's just so much content
there and so much stuff that you can do
they you can just play it literally
endlessly so switching gears a little
bit I'm a really big doom fan happen
since I was kid because my dad let me
play that game maybe he shouldn't have
that's a good dad you see as a good dad
but I really loved in 2016 and I have
some questions about doom eternal mainly
is it a direct sequel I don't know if
that's been said it has not and I I
can't really give any more info look
it's a sequel because it's the next doom
but where it sits in the timeline and
what the story is you have to wait til
quake on okay so more at QuakeCon one
less thing is it not called doom 2
because you can't keep doing the same
doom name that's definitely part of it
we were like yeah that's gonna be super
awkward if every doom game there was
already one called that and now we got
to use years in parentheses I really
wanted to call it doom 5 because I just
thought it would be really funny because
everybody thought the last one was
doomed 4 and so let's just jump way
ahead and mess with everybody but you
will actually also find out more about
the name and why it's relevant at
QuakeCon as it relates to what's going
on in the game and the story and so
forth but you know you know a little bit
hell on earth is at least a part of it
twice as many demons and definitely a
big goal was to make the do marine feel
even faster and more aggressive and more
powerful and having played the game a
bunch already I can tell you all of
those things are really really awesome
can't wait to August 10 alright so quake
on it is I guess on the sequel front and
the shooter front Wolfenstein Youngblood
I think was one of my favorite
announcements I'm a really big
Wolfenstein fan and I reviewed
Wolfenstein in classes and I'm just
really really looking forward to this
story and one of the things I was
wondering is it because the Youngblood
sounds like a play off of ol
blood I was wondering if this is like
Wolfenstein if this is a trilogy like
has been you know hinted at before is
this three or is this more of a
absolutely not no this is this is
separate you know we said we we
definitely want to continue the story
that we established with the new order
and the new Colossus but this is moving
things ahead eighteen years after the
last game after the new Colossus we're
not only of BJ's twin daughters been
born but they're grown up you see him
here in the teaser and it's about you
can play as either one of them and have
the other as an AI companion or if you
have a friend that you want to play with
they can play the other twin and you can
play through together but it's still at
its heart what Wolfenstein is known for
which is interesting characters
ass-kicking Nazis right like just
ripping - smashing tearing through them
in the ways that you would expect in a
wolf game and so I guess because you can
choose between the twins do they have
slightly different like do they feel
different to play different gameplay
styles mmm we should probably wait till
where I would love to tell you lots of
things about it but we're gonna wait a
little bit to the team's ready to not
only talk more about it but to actually
show you more so you can not just not
just hear about it but actually see like
okay I get it I get the difference fair
enough
and then we haven't even talked about
rage 2 yet we talked about a lot of
different games rage 2 was interesting
to me because you know you have Andrew W
K coming out with that like bonkers
off-the-wall song and then the the
gameplay had a similar tone but it was a
little different I think what I picked
up on was like the aid software shooting
style I was wondering you know is it all
gonna be like balls to the wall I don't
know if I can say that but you know
balls to the wall like crazy insanity
all the time or is there gonna be a
little bit of a you know slower more not
slower but it has a certain style so
it's shooting and I'm wondering how
those tones marry each other some of
that is under your control based on sort
of the powers that on you unlock and the
way that you play through but it's
really at its core meant to be a crazy
over-the-top open-world sandbox like the
it'd shooter that you know the way the
guns feel
the way the shotguns feel combined with
avalanches pedigree of
creating open worlds and really cool
vehicle combat and vehicle driving all
of those things combining into it's just
a lot of fun to play however you want
like if you just want to go exploring
around and stumble across content all
over the place you can if you want to
follow stories and do quests you can do
that too like it's really sort of
self-directed what what do you want it
to feel like you could spend you know
all your time driving around in vehicles
and just shooting up other caravans or
going into locations you know one of my
favorite clips and the trailer is when
you're engaged in combat with a bunch of
guys coming at you and all of a sudden
the car just comes flying down the road
like right through the midst of them
like that's what we want it to feel like
it's it's not one or the other it's just
sort of all happening at once but it's
it's player directed so yeah you could
make it as totally crazy as you want it
to be them yeah exactly
and then another thing I mean this is
forgive me for this question but we'll
get to pray in a second but you guys
announced DLC for prey the typhoon -
hunter not typhoon I was wondering if
we'll see other modes added to other
Bethesda games similarly I hesitate to
ask about battle royale but I gotta
we definitely have nothing battle royale
related that's not really been what you
know when people ask me like what is
Bethesda known for what is it Bethesda
game mean look at me and all kinds of
stuff it means this it means the Elder
Scrolls legends card game it means
fallout 76 lots of stuff that looks
different but we tend never to want to
follow anybody else into a space we
didn't go chasing after Facebook gaming
when that was the big trend
just because battle boreal is popular it
doesn't mean it's a good fit for us or
our studios we tend to be more informed
by what our teams want to do what
directions do they want to go how do
they want to evolve and grow both as a
studio as far as well as what their
games offer so like if somebody comes up
with the thing that's battle royale or
battle royale s that they think is
unique or different or cool it's
probably something we'd consider but we
tend not to go chasing after trends we
kind of wanted
pushing ourselves to offer different
experiences and do new things totally
understandable but I guess just any my
mean have seen prey get so much support
is really encouraging that's another
game I really love from last year and I
feel like a game like that can be hard
to add things to you know in some ways
so I was just wondering if you know
other games could get you know not
battle royale but any any sort of DLC
like me major and it sort of varies
cally like depending on the thing so for
example with the evil within a big one
we focused on wasn't necessarily content
but it was making the whole game
playable in first person because that
felt like a really good fit for that
we're like well maybe more DLC isn't
what folks are looking for or in the
case of Doom it was hey here's this
Arcade Mode so now you can still play
through the game but now the way that
you play through it feels very different
than just playing through the main
single-player story that we originally
shipped with so in each case it's like
let the teams come up with a what do
they want be what are the fans asking
for or looking for and then you know how
do we surprise and delight them right
like they were they were hoping I think
for news at e3 but to not only say hey
here's a big free up that you've been
waiting for but here's content and it's
all available tonight go play it right
now like that that's what I think is fun
to try and exceed folks expectations and
and to answer and deliver the kinds of
things they're looking for
speaking of surprising and delighting
fans I think we should probably wrap up
but this is my my final big question is
I want to know what the pitch meeting
for Skyrim on Alexa was like because I
thought it was just a joke and when I
found out I wrote the news story on that
when I found out it actually was on the
Alexus tour I lost my mind
it actually was developed in a very
similar way which was we know we get a
lot of flack for what else are you gonna
put Skyrim on so we're like well we're
just gonna own it and have fun with that
and make fun of ourselves and make fun
of everybody else and this by the way
was entirely Todd's idea from the
beginning but it just started off as a
joke and then it evolved into actually
we could make the game that we're joking
about and then like just troll them one
layer deeper where they think haha
that's really funny and the
etch-a-sketch in the fridge
then you find out that it's a real thing
and like we got you twice so I don't
know there's one of those things like it
started off simple but like a lot of
Todd things it turned out to be way
crazier and more complicated and awesome
as a result kind of ended up being the
ultimate joke so that no one can ever
make that joke again so I think
something like that yeah well that's all
the time we have I think thank you so
much for joining me this has been Pete
Hines global senior vice president of
Bethesda thank you again
fantastic show so far we're really
enjoying III thanks very much thanks for
having me right for more on Bethesda you
can check out GameSpot we have tons of
trailers all round up on all the news
all the games announced so check that
out if you missed anything and we'll see
you next time